de la bd sur les planches une initiative
plutôt originale elle est l'oeuvre de
deux auteurs de bandes dessinées qui
s'intéresse aussi à la musique et à la
vidéo ou à l'architecturé ils se sont
inspirés de l'un de leurs albums un
spectacle qui est présenté dans le cadre
du festival de musique contemporaine de
grenoble reportage une buvette et marc
felix
on sait seulement que cette jeune femme
mary ford braaten des ombres l'aurait
rencontrée dans la ville industrielle de
milos
mary von roten beau gustin de sombres
ces deux personnages n'aurait jamais dû
se croiser la première est née de
l'esprit fécond de françois schuiten et
benoît pétel auteurs de bande dessinée
le second est un peintre figuratif du
19e siècle totalement oublié rencontres
improbables
elle a pourtant donné naissance à un
album l'enfant pencher dont s'inspire
aujourd'hui ce spectacle foisonnant mais
leur musique jeux de scène dessin et
vidéos
on aime bien au fond toutes les images
qui sont un peu au croisement des
domaines savez il ya des gens qui croire
la peinture la photographie le cinéma la
bande dessinée nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est beaucoup plus toutes les
réalités de troubles tous les mondes de
l'antre 2 les auteurs il est vrai nous
ont accoutumé au mélange des genres peut
être le résultat de leur parcours benoît
peters philosophe disciple de roland
barthes
il s'essaie à tous les genres
artistiques françois schuiten une
famille d'architectes ils tombent très
tôt dans la marmite du dessin artiste
touche-à-tout influences multiples à
l'oeuvre dans les cités obscures une
série de treize albums dont l'enfant
pencher est sans doute l'un des plus
aboutis le vendre mais sinon c'est vrai
que déjà une forme d'expression assez
hybride et c'est dans cette je dirais
cette étude assez étrange qui mélangeait
textes dessins que nous on a été heureux
parfois d'un côté on prolonge cette fête
ce plaisir des arts passerelle jeu
étrange déroutant le spectacle de ce cui
tonnes et peters est dévoilée demain au
festival des 38e rugissants de grenoble
il fera escale à paris l'ordre famille